la medida principal es que se congelarán
los precios de las facturas de la
energía desde el primero de octubre en
2500 libras esterlinas al año que son
más o menos 2.900 dólares esta
congelamiento será por dos años hasta el
año 2024 también los negocios tendrán
apoyos por seis meses pero serán
revisados cada semestre y también los
hospitales las escuelas y otro tipo de
establecimientos tan tendrán el apoyo
que necesiten el panorama es grave
porque el incremento los precios de la
energía seguirá subiendo En octubre el
gobierno va congelado ese incremento
pero lo cierto es que los precios en una
casa promedio puede llegar al año a ser
hasta de 4000 dólares lo que significa
que el estado debe poner el excedente lo
que recargaría aún más la deuda pública
y podría convertirse en un mayor número
de inflación que ya en este país está
disparado pero el panorama es aún más
grave porque en el país Cuanto más se
utiliza energía es en el invierno para
calentar las casas con gas y
electricidad Así que el panorama puede
ser terminar siendo aún más delicado más
grave y esa es la gran preocupación que
tienen en este momento en una acalorado
debate en el parlamento que tuvo que ser
prácticamente suspendido por la
situación con la Reina Isabel el jefe de
la oposición dijo que deberían Entonces
aumentarse los impuestos para los las
grandes empresas de energía y de
hidrocarburos